un outil revirement demain 22 heures sur
public sénat
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition d' europe hebdo nous
sommes à strasbourg au parlement
européen
dans cette émission direction
l'allemagne nuremberg un pays leader de
l'économie européenne qui pourtant a du
mal à trouver de la main d'oeuvre
alors que faire tout simplement aller
chercher des diplômés à l'étranger où ça
dans les pays du sud de l'europe des
pays en crise nous en débattrons dans la
seconde partie de l'émission
mais d'abord l'actualité une fois de
plus l'île de lampedusa a été touché par
un drame de l'immigration
des centaines de corps sont jour après
jour repêché au large de ses côtes
alors que fait l'europe pour lampedusa
c'est la question de la semaine
c'est une mère de koor de corps humains
des africains venus chercher une vie
meilleure sur les rives d'une europe
chaleureuse accueillante protectrice
port de départ corne de l'afrique
porte d'entrée lampedusa une île
tristement célèbre pour être l'un des
principaux points d'entrée des migrants
dans l'union européenne
cette fois ils étaient près de 500 sur
ce bateau qui gît désormais par 45
mètres de fond à 600 mètres des côtes
seuls 150 sont vivantes et tous les
jours les plongeurs continuent leur lent
et macabre travail de remontée des corps
17 par 6 30 par là des hommes des femmes
des jeunes filles des enfants
pourtant on devrait s'y habituer à cette
valse des boat people en méditerranée
depuis 20 ans quelques dix sept mille
migrants ont trouvé la mort sur les
rives de l'europe dans la presque
indifférence générale non à chaque
naufrage
à chaque vague de noyer la même
compassion les mêmes larmes et les mêmes
débats frontex
mais que fait l'agencé frontex qui
sécurise les frontières extérieures de
l'union
et cette fameuse politique migratoire
commune et s'ils ont convoqué une
réunion des responsables à 8 y un très
bonne idée
et puis après après rien jusqu'au
prochain naufrage alors l'europe prix
nobel de la paix on a abandonné dans
pizza
l'europe at-elle oublié lampedusa a pour
répondre à cette question c'est sylvie
guillaume qui nous a rejoints sur ce
plateau merci d'être avec nous bonjour
vous êtes vice présidente du groupe
socialiste et démocrate et membre de la
commission des affaires intérieures de
la des libertés civiles et de la justice
alors selon vous qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour l'en pedrosa est ce que vraiment
lampedusa finalement c'est juste quelque
chose qui vient un petit peu réglé de
temps en temps quelques deux trois fois
dans l'année
l'actualité européenne on convoque des
réunions et derrière pas grand chose
votre reportage même s'il a un ton
caustique a été voulue sautier voulu
bien entendu décrit assez bien la
réalité c'est à dire cet enchaînement
d'un bateau qui coule ou qui menacent de
couler des morts de la compassion des
larmes de crocodile une demande de
réunion quelques déplacements et
finalement la vie continue et où la mort
continue
et c'est un peu ça que je reproche
effectivement dans cet enchaînement
c'est que ça a eu des lampes et 12 ha il
y aura d'autres lampes et dosage si on
ne bouge pas effectivement de façon
beaucoup plus massives sur ce sujet de
l'accès des migrations en général j'ai
exprimé tout à l'heure auprès du
commissaire barnier la chose suivante
c'est que bien sûr s'occuper de tel ou
tel aspect des politiques migratoires
est important en soi la pièce de l'asile
est important la pièce des travailleurs
saisonniers est important la pièce de la
sécurité est importante la pièce de
frontex est importante mais personne ne
songe réellement à faire en sorte de
rassembler ces pièces est de construire
réellement une politique cohérente
globale sur l'émigration est ce que
l'europe a besoin de migration est ce
que on est suffisamment les gens qui ont
besoin qu'ils veulent ou qui ont besoin
de se déplacer
quel corridor on met pour qu'ils
accèdent à l'europe si c'est nécessaire
s'ils en ont besoin
voir toutes ces questions là finalement
on se les posent pas de façon commune
les réunions qui sont organisés n'aborde
finalement pas l'essentiel
mais plutôt par petits morceaux
l'intérêt de tels états membres
l'intérêt de tel autre état membre qui
sont quelquefois contradictoires et
finalement on en tire des grandes
déclarations mais sans vraiment
deux décisions concrètes alors on a
souvent une fois de plus entendu parler
de l' agence frontex qui est l' agence
qui gère en fait les frontières
extérieures qui est censé les sécuriser
sur le prochain budget donc qui aura qui
prendra en 2014 au 1er janvier 2014 on
voit qu'il ya quand même une baisse
drastique on passe de 118 millions à 84
millions
est-ce que c'est pas un mauvais signal
finalement les signaux ont toujours été
très mauvais vis-à-vis de frontex en
tout cas de son budget puisque fonds
texte une agence récente qui est passé
d'un budget je crois de mémoire des six
millions à son origine de 2005 à 95
milliers millions puis en baisse
maintenant sur ce budget donc mais si
nos étés à la fois très mauvais parce
qu'il ya une augmentation exponentielle
uniquement axé sur la sécurisation des
frontières alors qu'il ya d'autres
aspects c'est nécessaire on dit surtout
de frontex que c'est une agence
répressive et qui n'est pas du tout en
fait dans le cadre de l'accompagnement
des migrants alors son rôle n'est pas
non plus l'accompagnement mais il c'est
vrai qu'il ya eu un saut qualitatif avec
le nouveau règlement frontex que nous
avons mis au point il ya maintenant deux
ans je termine juste sur l'aspect
budgétaire le côté yoyo effectivement du
budget de frontex n'est pas très
sécurisant
c'est le cas de le dire pour cette
agence mais j'en reviens donc à ce
règlement qui a changé pour faire en
sorte que font texte soit effectivement
dans son rôle de sécurisation des
frontières mais également dans son rôle
de protection des personnes viendra
s'ajouter à ce rôle là aussi on va voter
cette cette session sur ce sujet le
dispositif euros sur qui est lui un
dispositif d'échangé d'informations
notamment satellitaires entre les
différents états membres pour sécuriser
la vie des personnes qui sont dans ces
bateaux vers la surveillance ray
élites et les échanges entre états pour
voir effectivement avoir en aide chaque
fois il faut de mon point de vue
toujours accolé à 20,8 une facette de
sécurisation des frontières mais
évidemment de sécurisation de la vie des
gens qui sont dans ces bateaux et c'est
indispensable pour moi de les accoler
alors il ya une question qui se repose
une fois de plus à chaque fois qu'il ya
un drame qui se déroule à lampedusa
j'aimerais qu'on écoute une
représentante de la lance amnesty
international
brosseau de weekendtour collective peut
être que nous pouvons parler d'un
système d'asile plus collectif avec
l'union européenne
cela ne peut pas continuer ainsi il y à
des politiques au sein de l'union qui
met l'accent sur le premier pays
d'entrée des migrants football
sylvie guillaume est ce qu'il faut
changer ce règlement qui dit que la
prise en charge en fait de l'asile doit
se faire par le pays d'entrée le premier
pays d'entrée en europe la représentant
de l'italie par la représentante
d'amnesty international et vous-même
venez d'évoquer le règlement dit dublin
qui vient d'être modifié dans le cadre
de la réforme du paquet asile qui
comprenait plusieurs textes dont ce
règlement dublin
la modification nous l'avions souhaité
au parlement européen nous avions trouvé
une forme d'accord pour aller dans ce
sens de faire en sorte que le premier
pays d'entrée et on sait que les pays du
pourtour de l'europe sont les plus
sujets à ses entrées ne soit pas
forcément les seuls à assumer le
traitement des demandes d'asile
nous ne sommes pas parvenus à trouver un
accord sur la modification du règlement
dublin ii dont dublin 3 2 comprend
effectivement pas cette disposition
c'est l'allemagne qui bloquent entre
autres pas que l'allemagne l'avait
notamment l'allemagne d'autres états
membres n'étaient pas favorables
effectivement elle à cette modification
en laissant effectivement la charge de
l'examen des demandes d'asile
principalement aux pays qui sont
confrontés aux afflux massif alors il ya
là le problème en fait de ces mafias de
passeurs qui au souvenir donc ces
réfugiés
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas régler le
problème à la base qui est enfin ouvrir
la politique des visas en europe afin de
faire venir de manière légale ces
réfugiés potentiels sur les territoires
européens pour qu'ils puissent demander
l'asile dans des conditions enfin
humaine si je puis dire et ne pas tenter
le passage qui leur coûte la vie
aujourd'hui
m il faut considérer les choses de me
semble-t-il de la manière suivante c'est
à dire que plus les routes sont coupées
plus les voies légales d'accès à
l'europe qu'il s'agisse de la migration
de travail qu'il s'agisse de l'asile et
je fais la distinction ya pas une voie
d'accès unique qui soit l'asie mais il
peut y avoir effectivement de la
migration régulière par le biais de
l'accès au travail plus ces routes légal
régulière sont coupés plus les routes
il est régulier
ce sont se sont renforcés et plus les
passeurs font de l'argent sur ces
passages l'a donc par parallélisme des
formes
il faut que l'union prenne conscience
qu'elle doit organiser c'est ce que je
faisais référence tout à l'heure quand
je parle de migration de politique
migratoire général et coordonnée il faut
que l'union réfléchissent à la manière
d'ouvrir des voies régulière d'accès
c'en est une limite est justement le
recours à ces passages réguliers qui
font des morts à lampedusa ailleurs à
d'autres frontières de l'algérie gréco
turque elle peut notamment au passage je
vais vous poser la dernière question je
voudrais me réponse très courte
est ce que finalement à la veille de ces
élections européennes de 2014
on a envie au sein de l'union que ce
soit conseil commission parlement
d'ouvrir ce dossier et de réfléchir à
une politique commune sur cette question
est-ce que c'est pas ouvrir la boîte de
pandore et se tirer une balle dans le
pied
je pense que le parlement a eu ces
dernières années ses nombreuses
dernières années l'envy de partage et de
partager ce discours lie de travailler
sur ces questions
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit une envie
partagée merci sylvie guillaume d'avoir
participer avec nous à ce débat nous on
continue sur les questions migratoires
l'allemagne est un pays qui souffre d'un
cruel déficit de main d'oeuvre et pour
faire face à ce problème elle va tout
simplement chercher des diplômés à
l'étranger où ça dans les pays en crise
en europe la grèce l'espagne ou l'italie
c'est un reportage de mélanie montant et
paul bouffard en allemagne
8h52 c'est un employé comme les autres
qui passent les tourniquets depuis 2011
christos travail ici près de nuremberg
gh chez siemens energy
mais l'ingénieur de 35 ans vient de loin
il a fui la grèce et sa crise du jour au
lendemain
son salaire a été divisé par deux je
n'ai pas mis beaucoup de temps à trouver
du travail en allemagne grâce un
chasseur de têtes
thessalonique en grèce j'ai reçu une
invitation de la semaine c'est j'ai eu
un entretien dans bourges et un mois
plus tard
christos est en poste expert en énergie
cieslik une immigration facilité il
trouve son logement en ligne et les
formalités administratives réglées par
l'employeur ma fiancée est médecin elle
travaille actuellement en grèce et nous
avons vu d'ailleurs qu'elles viennent
ici en allemagne et qu'elle cherche elle
aussi à un travail lorsque nous nous
voulons fonder une famille notre famille
ici l'entreprise crée même un pôle
d'ingénieurs étrangers
après avoir sonné l'austérité les
allemands accueille les cerveaux hélène
dans le service huit employés sur disque
sont originaires de grèce c'est devenu
difficile de trouver des experts
allemands dans ce domaine il n'ya pas de
spécialisation sismique en allemagne on
doit aller plus au sud de l'europe
nous devons trouver en grèce en italie
ou en turquie mais la grèce restent la
meilleure option
aujourd'hui 42 % des allemands ont plus
de 50 ans si rien n'est fait le pays
manquera de six millions de travailleurs
d'ici dix ans alors ingénieur expert
mais aussi personnels de santé
deviennent une cible prioritaire pour
les chasseurs de tête à l'agencé
allemande pour l'emploi
on développe même une campagne
européenne de recrutement the job of my
life présente sur toutes les bourses à
l'emploi d'europe du sud
objectif draguer les travailleurs
étrangers ici en allemagne le chômage
est relativement limité le taux de
chômage en août était de 6,3 pour cent
ce qui est très faible comparé à
l'europe
dans un pays comme la grèce il est de 27
% ce qui est évidemment très élevés et
c'est pourquoi nous ne pouvons
qu'encourager les travailleurs grecs à
venir chez nous à venir à nous quand ils
ont bien sûr des je pense que quand la
croissance reviendra en grèce et bien
ces travailleurs reviendront dans leur
pays
avec bien entendu leurs compétences et
en plus
depuis 12 mois
pas moins de vingt-cinq mille nouveaux
travailleurs grecs sont arrivés en
allemagne alors comme un nuremberg les
communautés s'organise dionysos tous les
grecs disent ils le connaissent c'est un
peu l'ange gardien de ses compatriotes
avec son association il fait la
passerelle entre grèce et allemagne aide
administrative mais pas seulement des
cours d'allemand aussi maîtriser la
langue de goethe reste un sésame
indispensable pour décrocher ces emplois
ça a commencé il ya deux ans pour nous
aussi c'était quelque chose de nouveau
et beaucoup de grecs sont venues d'un
coup des familles des jeunes des enfants
et il faisait la queue devant notre
bureau
c'est un étang de rien des ingénieurs
mathématiciens des professeurs et bien
sûr aussi des médecins
beaucoup de médecins et c'est le cas de
vasiliadis docteur en biologie
moléculaire et génétique blessé par la
caricature des grecs paresseux diffusé
en allemagne
il a quand même fait le voyage car en
grèce il n'avait qu'un petit boulot de
chauffeur de taxi il a bien failli se
retrouver à dormir dans la rue comme ils
le
son pays ne pouvait plus le faire vivre
je peux comprendre la plupart des
européens leur vision de la situation en
grèce
mais il y en a un que je ne comprends
pas c'est schloegel le ministre des
finances allemand
il a dit que c'était de la faute des
grecs il peut bien sûr accusé le
gouvernement qui a mal diriger le pays
mais il ne doit pas accuser le peuple si
on m'appelait et qu'on visait tu as une
offre d'emploi en grèce je serai dans le
premier avion pour y retourner pour
l'instant vasiliadis continue son
aventure dans l'eldorado allemand son
équivalence de diplôme tamponné en main
l'homme est en attente d'un poste à
l'hôpital de nuremberg
et pour évoquer cette question de la
main d'oeuvre en allemagne ce sont deux
députés qui nous ont rejoints sur ce
plateau andrée h fab
bonjour vous êtes député européen
allemand membre du groupe ppe
merci d'être avec nous jean luc
bennahmias vous êtes français membre du
groupe libéraux-démocrates et surtout
vous êtes membre de la commission emploi
après avoir visionné ce reportage je
voudrais juste vous poser une question
de reals femmes
auparavant l'allemagne avait pour
habitude d'aller chercher des immigrés
entre guillemets qualifiés dans les pays
de l'est
pourquoi ce choix d'aller vers les pays
en crise alors moi en tant que député je
ne suis pas en liaison avec cette
entreprise ce faire vous avez montré
mais c'est vrai que le marché européen
cela donne est de plus en plus à marcher
pour les citoyens de choisir quoi faire
et où moi aussi quand j'étais jeune
j'avais pensé de travailler à paris mais
malheureusement il y évoque aucun aucun
travail et donc je pense que si les gens
peuvent décider eux mêmes comment ils
veulent vivre et où le travail et je
trouve c'est super qu'ils viennent en
allemagne et de travailler je suis enfin
là pour le coup c'est super pour eux de
venir parce qu'il trouve une opportunité
mais pourquoi faire ce choix d'aller et
on le voit bien dans ce reportage
explicitement cibler des pays en crise
où vous savez que le taux d'emploi des
diplômés est très bas il ya une part un
petit peu de d'opportunisme si je puis
dire entre guillemets exactement pour
cette raison je ne vous pas donné cette
réponse car je n'ai pas décidé en tant
que député européen
ce choix je ne sais pas sur quelles
bases siemens a pris cette décision dans
le reportage des mondialistes mais c'est
aussi le pôle emploi enfin l' agence
pour l'emploi national il ya cette
campagne ce n'est pas que si mais je
pense ça nous amène dans un climat où
dans une discussion plus large et plus
profonde la question si les gens n'ont
pas envie de travailler de trouver un
bon boulot et je pense il ya beaucoup de
gens qui cherchent un bon boulot et si
le trouve en pologne en france ou en
allemagne c'est mieux de ne pas avoir un
boulot vous monsieur bennahmias cette
circulation comme ça des diplômes et
finalement c'est plutôt bénéfique pour
paulin si c'est volontaire et on le voit
que c'est contradictoire complexe c'est
volontaire je vois aucune difficulté
voulu travailler à paris moi je pourrais
travailler très bien travaillé en
allemagne avant tout à ce niveau là j'ai
pas de problème quand c'est involontaire
et c'est la situation de la grèce les
catastrophiques comme celle de l'espagne
voire celle du portugal où assa nombre
de diplômés ne trouvent pas d'emploi
même si des non-diplômés aussi et lacées
pas volontaire et globalement quand même
moi je crains tu pas l'allemagne
les relations entre l'allemagne et la
grèce notamment touristiques depuis
plusieurs dizaines d'années entre le
nombre d'allemands qui était qui passait
en vacances en grèce et elle est
absolument gigantesque plusieurs
millions sont pleins et les rapports de
couple il ya des relations relativement
normale depuis évidemment plus de 5 en
près de 50 ans donc voilà non ce qui est
ce qui est agaçant ce que j'ai entendu
au début du reportage c'est que j'ai pas
très bien compris pourquoi les
reproduire une baisse de salaire là je
comprends pas je savais pas que les
salaires en grèce était aussi haut ce
que je sais c'est que salaire de cadre
en allemagne sont relativement
normalement élevé la la la la baisse de
salaire c'est vrai que vu que son
salaire a été divisé par deux en grèce
il a fait le choix d'un jury quatre ans
j'ai mal compris ses excuses et moi
c'est moi qui va le compris voilà après
voilà il faut qu'on arrive à mon avis je
le dis souvent qu'on arrive à trouver
une fiscalité commune au niveau
entreprise entreprenariale dans le cadre
de l'union européenne notamment été
grande pays la france l'allemagne et
aussi la grèce pour que globalement
siemens aille aussi faire travailler des
gens directement en grèce et pas
uniquement par des espèces d'allers et
retours mais c'est pas sur le fond qui
est circulation des salariés avec les
mêmes droits et les mêmes devoirs et les
mêmes droits dès demain les droits du
travail ne paraît pas spécialement à
conséquence alors il ya une accusation
de la part des syndicats allemands qui
voit assez mal si je puis dire cette
arrivée massive que ce soit d'employer
grec portugais italiens ou espagnols
c'est que pour eux il ya une forme de
dumping sur les salaires c'est à dire
s'il ya une pression sur le marché du
travail pour maintenir des salaires plus
bas en faisant appel à l'immigration
qu'est ce que vous avez à répondre à ces
syndicats bon alors moi je n'ai pas
entendu ces syndicats dont vous parlez
donc je peux pas vraiment comprendre ce
que voulait dire a lancé il y a même
repris par là
w7 à l'institut berlinois mais il y a
cet institut il y à aussi l'institut
d'une agence de travail en allemagne et
qui ont fait des sondages car souvent on
critique le salaire minimum qui n'existe
pas encore en allemagne devraient être
introduites mais ces études si on les
lit jusqu'à la fin et malheureusement
c'est pas toujours fait ils disent aussi
que finalement le salaire minimum
n'indique pas où la participation d'un
certain nombre de gens à cela un salaire
plus bas que le salaire minimum dans
d'autres pays n'appliquent pas du tout
que la le comment dire le niveau de vie
est vraiment plus bas le niveau de vie
c'est ça ce qu'il faut prendre en
considération est souvent en état qu'on
finance où ces gens là ont 2 2 ou 3
boulot ou 1,2 en août un boulot en
addition est donc pour juger le marché
travaillent en allemagne
d'abord il faut accepter qu'il ya très
peu de chômage surtout très peu de
chômage des jeunes je crois à contresens
% pour la moyenne de la loi la très
chaud très peu de chômage des jeunes et
donc les gens ont envie de travailler
maintenant il faut trouver le salaire
juste ça c'est clair
mais de mon point de vue dans la plupart
des situations en allemagne c'est un
salaire juste et on est en train de
l'améliorer on peut toujours faire mieux
c'est aucune question
mais je pense qu'il faut pas assez de ce
débat vers un départ de dans ping social
le dumping social c'est quand c'est pour
ça qu'il faut faire en sorte que les
gens qui cherchent un travail et ne le
trouve pas sont pas mis de côté mais on
a une chance de trouver un boulot dans
le marché de travail c'est aussi quelque
chose qui les satisfait quitté
additionnée de trois enfants jean luc
beylat bien son nom est clairement je
parle de ça dépend des emplois mais
quand on a un emprunt de on est on est
sans emploi de cadre supérieur de 2 août
de hautes qualifications je ne vois
absolument pas comment on peut cumuler
plusieurs emplois de notre qualification
docteur chimistes biologistes et pour
moi totalement impossible un conséquent
il faut les salaires qu'ils soient des
salaires à des revenus honorable
respectable moi je pense que on doit
arriver à cela l'allemagne va aller vers
un salaire
mais on parle pas des mêmes emplois dans
ces cas là on parle de salaire minimum
c'est pas les mêmes emplois l'histoire
du dumping si si je me mets en france
mais en france on fait travailler dans
la médecine générale et la médecine dans
nos pieds d'ailleurs dans les hôpitaux
français s'est attaché et bâillonné
bulgarie serait bien ou roumains à des
salaires qu'ils sont égal au smic
donc il sait pas une question de dumping
ya une question derrière tout cela de
comment on arrive réellement dr à mettre
en face des emplois réellement existant
des formations réellement existante
problème français mais aussi bizarrement
d'ailleurs problème allemand aujourd'hui
j'apprends ça pas partout vous êtes
quand même meilleur que nous par rapport
à ça par rapport à la formation
professionnelle non je lui dis c'est la
réalité
mais quand même il ya le même problème
donc voilà après ça le dumping social il
existe sur quoi sur le btp
tout le monde le sait sont les
travailleurs saisonniers dans tout ce
qui est agriculture saisonnières là où
il ya des choses à améliorer
qui sont d'ailleurs je le dis on en
israël beaucoup au niveau de la
commission sociale au parlement européen
sur ce qu'on appelle les travailleurs
détachés
ça nous touche tous et sur ce qu'on
avait des travailleurs saisonniers et on
améliore les situations directive après
directive c'est pas le summum
mais on les améliore alors je voudrais
qu'on écoute le grec qu'on a vu à
l'instant dans le reportage
il a une question directe à vous poser
l'europe connaît une de ses pires crises
c'est vraiment historique la solidarité
est peut-être la meilleure solution que
les citoyens européens peuvent partager
pour surmonter cette crise
qu'est ce que vous allez faire dans ce
sens
sur luc bennahmias vous riez à l'instant
à l'abri parce que bon je suis très
français j'aime bien mais l'allemagne a
une responsabilité particulière dans la
situation économique d'aujourd'hui une
responsabilité avec madame merkel et
avec les accords qui semblerait-il
serait passé avec le spd donc sur une
union démocratique extrêmement forte
l'allemagne vit bien l'allemagne à une
exploitation extrêmement importante
avant 75 % par rapport à l'europe et
donc elle a entre les mains un ensemble
de la de dollars de la réhabilitation de
la reconstruction de l'union européenne
donc des pays qui sont à côté grèce
france tous les pays qui l'entourent et
donc à ce niveau là c'est quand la main
et je moi je
sérieusement je leur fais assez
confiance pour être responsable pour
nous tous j'attends de voir comment les
choses vont se passer après la
cohabitation tels que vous allez la voir
mais je crois sérieusement que
globalement vu le pouvoir économique
aujourd'hui de l'allemagne et le
potentiel c'est à eux de faire que les
la crise dans laquelle les crises avec
elle nous sommes on puisse en sortir
y en a qui sont plus ou moins en crise
notamment la grèce andreas schwab
comment est ce que vous pouvez répondre
à ce monsieur qu'on a vu à l'instant
sachant que et on l'a vu dans le
reportage également beaucoup de grecs
qui sont actuellement en allemagne se
sont sentis lourdement stigmatisés et il
voit une forme de cynisme dans le fait
que vous alliez aujourd'hui chercher en
fait ces diplômés qui ont été formés par
la grèce avec les impôts grecs si
toutefois effectivement ils ont été
récupérés je voulais sourire qu'est ce
que vous avez à répondre sur cette
question de la solidarité est ce qu a
pas une forme de cynisme un petit peu là
dedans
non vraiment vraiment je ne pense pas
c'est un certain
chantage je pense vraiment ce monsieur
là c'était son choix de venir travailler
là et je trouve c'est une très bonne
idée et il n'est pas obligé de rester il
va incertain en avoir la possibilité
probablement de rentrer en grèce et de
aider à la population en grèce de
remonter et je pense d'abord l'europe a
dû prendre des mesures importantes pour
quoi car vous savez le débat sur le
respect des règles européen soit au
niveau du marché intérieur soit au
niveau des trois de travailleurs soit au
niveau
vous pouvez trouver et chercher
n'importe où ça n'a jamais été respecté
et donc maintenant d'ailleurs à la
pauvre grèce maintenant il faut pas à
tenir aux règles
non il faut commencer un certain moment
de faire respecter les règles n'importe
où aussi en allemagne et en france mais
aussi en grèce et deuxièmement malgré
ses problèmes qu'on a eus avec le
respect du droit européen n'importe où
en europe
on a été solidaires et c'est vrai que ça
va pas finir là et pourquoi
car on a besoin l'un de l'autre et il
faut communiquer cela est de mon point
de vue les grecs qui vont venir en
allemagne vont pas trouver un pays qui
est complètement stigmatisé par un
parent discussions contre la grèce n'ont
pas du tout les gens sont bien
conscients que la grèce est un pays et
que la politique grecque c'est autre
chose et que c'est pas toujours très
facilement a séparés l'un de l'autre
mais quand même
la solidarité c'est quelque chose qui
s'explique mais qui se prouve aussi que
ceux qui prennent la solidarité peuvent
démontrer qu'il fasse un peu plus pour
le respect des règles est rapide
notamment historiques pendant la
dictature des colonels en grèce
quels étaient les pays qui accueillait
les populations grecques l'allemagne et
la france et la suède aussi donc à ce
niveau là moi je crois pas qu'ils
antagonismes il ya après évidemment
circulation parfois volontaire et
parfois malheureusement forcées des
salariés parce qu'il abandonnait à une
période de crise gigantesque dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons bon écoutez
ce sera le mot de la fin
merci à tous les deux d'avoir accepté de
participer à ce débat
je vous laisse retourner dans
l'hémicycle où on continue du tout du
moins la semaine prochaine vous
retrouverez amat asira à bruxelles
je vous souhaite une très bonne suite de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires